[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick cannon and daughter monroe are all
in their emotions
[Music]
the father-daughter duo start their day
off right dancing and singing along to a
classic bop by monroe's mom and nick's
ex mariah carey
[Applause]
[Music]
i love making uh tick tocks with them
and stuff like that in the clip nick and
monroe use blankets as accessories
showing off their impressive moves while
jamming out to the chorus
rose you know fun and silly and as you
can see outgoing and amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i would say like monroe definitely gives
you the mariah vibes
and of course after lip syncing along to
mariah's signature whistle tone nick
gives a shout out to emcee tagging her
in the caption we have kids together so
we'll always be family nikki mariah's
share monroe and her twin brother
moroccan being a father is my first
priority in life the proud dad loves
spending quality time with the kiddos
and recently in a major way
whole water park just to ourselves
the rock and roll take over
yeah nick rented out an entire water
park for the twins talk about racking up
all the cool dad
and when points comes to their famous
mama well nick's got nothing but love
for his ex he recently admitted she'll
always hold a special place in his heart
come on that's my fantasy love that's
somebody i will always love i will never
have a love like i have with mariah if i
had the opportunity to if it could be
the way that it was i'm there
always be my baby
[Music]
that comment got a lot of fans
speculating is this just uh
[Music]
or could it be
[Music]
well when he co-hosted et last month he
gave us a little context i was talking
about the fantasy of it all and i was
like yo if i could have that same vibe
of where i was at that state in my life
and that age of course i would do that
all over again but i'm like clearly
there's a lot going on in my life now
it's completely different from that
we're still so like close friends the
best of friends great parents together
so i appreciate you know that time in my
life obviously we've all grown and
evolved and went separate ways but it
was still the like the biggest fantasy
of my life and when asked if uh the
door's still open nick had this
hilarious response all right don't want
me
he's just showing with all my thousand
kids like hey
[Music]